I think most of us have a sense
that payday loans are
probably not the best source for
a loan, that they probably
charge a lot of money to those
people who need that cash
really badly.
And what I want to do in this
video is one, explain what
they are but even more do
a little bit of math to
understand really how bad of
an interest that they do
charge,
So the way that works is let's
say that I need to buy my wife
a nice gift for her birthday
that's tomorrow and I want to
borrow $500.
So I want to borrow $500.
I would suspect that most people
aren't borrowing it for
some type of a gift, they're
desperate to make the rent or
pay the utilities or buy food
or who knows what else, but
whatever your reason, you need
to borrow $500 and I would
suspect that you have very
little in your bank account,
otherwise you wouldn't go
to the payday lendor.
And they say all right Sal,
we're open to lending you $500
and we're not going to do all
of this deep research on how
good of a credit you are and
all of that, but we want a
couple of things.
One, we want to know your pay
stub and your pay date.
They're going to want to see
your pay stub, they're going
to they want to know when you're
going to get paid, so I
guess we call it your payday.
And they might want some
recent bank statements.
And the whole reason why they
want these things is they want
to know you know even though
your credit might be horrible,
then you're going to get your
salary or you're going to to
get a payment from your employer
probably in two weeks
on your payday, and then you're
going to be good to pay
back to the $500.
And to ensure this, so one
they're going to make sure
that you have a job, that in
your pay stub maybe you make
$1,000 every two weeks or maybe
you make $2,000 every
two weeks so that you're
good for this.
So maybe you maybe make $1,500
every two weeks, so they like
to see that.
Maybe your payday is two weeks
from the day that you're
borrowing it, borrowing
the money.
So two weeks from today.
And then your bank statement
shows that your bank kind of
goes up $1,500 and you pay the
rent and the food and then it
goes back close to zero, then it
goes up to $1,500 but they
want to see that this $1,500
is hitting periodically.
And they say, you know,
we're going to give
you the $500 today.
You need to write us a check.
We want you to write a check for
not $500, for every $100
you borrow, I want you to
pay us back another $25.
So $25 extra.
And at first you might say,
that's not bad, that's 25%
interest. It's high, maybe it
compares to some interest,
some credit cards.
But this isn't 25% a year, this
is 25% for two weeks.
And at the end of this video,
we're going to do the map on
what that actually turns
into on an APR, or an
effective APR basis.
And these numbers are not crazy,
these are actually very
typical for payday loans.
So if I'm borrowing $500, I
have to give them back the
$500 in two weeks plus
$25 for every $100.
So I'm borrowing $500, so I'm
going to have to do plus five
times 25 five or $125.
So I'm going to write them a
check for $500 plus a $125 so
that's $625.
I'm going to write a check, but
obviously I don't have the
money in my bank account right
now, otherwise I wouldn't even
be going to the payday loan.
What I'm going to do on
the date, I'm going to
forward-date this check.
I'm going to put the date, let's
say this is the first of
the month, instead of let's say,
it's January 1, I'm going
to put January 16 and whatever
year I might be doing it.
So I've forwarded it, this
is two weeks from today.
Two weeks in the future, and
then I'm going to sign the
check and I'll write it's for
a payday loan and I'll write
$625 etc. etc., then I have my
little information here.
And I'm going to give them this
check and what they're
going to say is we're not going
to cash this, we're just
going to keep this nice little
check for us and when your
payday hits you have
an option.
You can come back to us and give
us $625 in cash and then
we will give you back this check
that is uncashed or if
you don't show up, we are just
going to cash this check.
So one of these two things
are going to happen.
But effectively, if you didn't
lie to them, they're going to
essentially charge you $625
and you can imagine it is
risky for the lender or because
these are people with
you know be maybe shady pay
stubs and obviously they're
desperate, so they weren't
good at managing their
finances, but they're doing
their best to ensure that once
that payday comes in, once
that's that payment from the
employer comes in, that they
get first dibs was on the
money before the person can
pay their rent or their
utilities or their food.
And so that's the general
idea behind it.
Now we start off saying this
probably not a good idea and
you got a sense of that, because
we're essentially
paying 25% interest for every
two weeks, not for every year.
But let's think about what
that is on an APR basis.
So let's say we're paying $25
for every $100, that's really
25 per cent.
When you say per cent, that
root means hundred, right?
Century, 100 years.
So per cent, it literally
means per 100.
25 per 100, so this is literally
25% interest or we
could write it the traditional
way, this is 25%
interest per two weeks.
So if we were just calculate a
simple APR, a simple annual
percentage interest rate, and
you might want to watch the
video on that to understand that
that just takes your 25%
and then multiplies by the
number of periods in the year.
So we have 52 weeks per year,
but this is every two weeks,
so instead of multiplying it
by 52 weeks, we're going to
multiply by there's 26 two-week
periods in the year.
So times 26 two-week
periods per year.
And this is 25% per two weeks.
When you multiply this out, this
is equal to-- let's get
the calculator out-- I'll just
multiply the numbers, I won't
do the decimals.
25 times 26 equal to 650%.
We're paying an APR of 650%.
So if you thought the credit
card companies were charging a
lot of interest, charging you
a mid teens interest rate or
20% rate, this is 650%.
It's an order of magnitude
or two above what even credit
cards charge.
So this is a really, really,
crazy annual percentage rate
and this was just a simple
annual percentage rate where
we multiplied it by 26, this
isn't the effective annual
percentage rate, or the actual
mathematically correct one.
To do that, we would actually
have to take-- and you might
want to watch the video on
this-- if you were to let that
just compound, and you can
imagine if you're the payday
lender, you are essentially
getting that compounding if
you keep lending your money
out and if you lend the
interest you get from the last
person, and you lend that out
the same rate.
To figure out that effective
annual percent rate, you do
1.25, 25% plus 1 to
the 26th power.
We have 26 of these
periods in a year.
And what is that going
to be equal to?
So we have 1.25 to
the 26th power.
And then we get this crazy
number, we're going to want to
subtract a 1 from it, not
that it's going to
change much of our math.
So minus 1, and we get, well
let me be very clear--
essentially this is 329
times our money.
So this if this was a one here,
that would be 100%.
So let me just be clear, this
number right here that number
right there is such a high
number it's hard to fathom.
If you were to actually let
money compound at this rate,
and usually they would make
you at least roll over the
principal, so this may or may
not be accurate but that
actual payday lender, if they
actually are able to roll over
the money at this rate, they're
going to have 329
times their money.
Or if you write it as
a percent, it would
literally be 32,987.
Literally, 32,987%.
Or after a year, you'll
essentially have to pay
roughly 330 times your money
back to the payday lender.
And obviously they don't let
you compound like that, but
this just gives you a sense
of how ridiculous this
interest rate is.
I mean, you might have heard
of the term usury.
In the past, usury really meant
any kind of interest,
but now in our current cultural
context we associate
it with just an unreasonable
level of interest and that
threshold might be different
for some people.
Some people might say it's
unreasonable to pay 20%, or
30% interest, or 40% annual
interest. But I think everyone
would agree that whether you
look at 650% or 33,000%, these
are usurious and reasonable
interest rates.
So you really, at all costs,
unless your life depends on
it, you want to avoid
these payday loans.